there's something to understand on on on
locks in idealized environments so if if
I was going to do nikel nikel can't be
on when my hand goes down okay uh Niko's
already on Niko's already on try to
stand
up you get it it's not I don't go here
and then go down you see how it's off
and then on as as soon as I come it's on
it's on right away if I'm going to do
katame same thing here it's not off and
then on okay so if I'm if I'm here it's
on already even even if it looks like
it's not completed it's on already okay
if I'm going to do katama again as I'm
working it it's already on so that I
don't have to do these movements do you
see right as we land he want wanted to
tap okay so the same
thing if I'm
working this lock if I make these if I
have to make these big gross movements
then it's not going to it's not ideal
okay so let's say he's pushing on me
right and as I'm working that same body
it's it's already on which I won't do
the mat part but it's on already do you
see yes sir so when I get here
that's why you notice that I didn't
really move and it's already
on you don't have to do these big
movements save that for when it counts
okay but when you're idealized
environment you you should be tight at
contact and it's only getting tighter
without the movement going on okay all
right